especially if you have a slightly higher
than normal testosterone account you're
going to think that you can fight
whether or not you actually can they
have in their head this idea that i can
goku my way out of this [ __ ] i can power
up based on anger and red bull or
whatever and win a fight when the
difference between somebody who's
trained for like just six months it's
astronomical the amount of ability
that's there just from learning the
basics
frost welcome to the show
hey great to be here this is awesome
uh it's been a few days now we've had
enough time for the lessons from will
smith slapping chris rock to percolate
around the internet and their
philosophical significance to embed
themselves
what were your thoughts when you first
saw that and what are your thoughts now
having had time to reflect on it
well like every single human being that
is even moderately aware of this i had
my own take on this and it was
it was basically this you know i thought
will smith could hit harder you know
but you know it's
not the most earnest uh way of looking
at that yeah i mean
i don't think he was trying to knock
chris rock's head off um a lot of people
given what we do uh at bulshito thought
oh it was a work it was staged it was
you know the oscars nobody cares about
him anymore and now we're all talking
about it so um i don't have a strong
opinion one way or another but yeah i i
was just like hey action movies aren't
reality let's just take this opportunity
to remind you of that
interesting one i
on balance i don't think that it's a
fake
event i don't think it makes as much
sense i'd heard that if it came about
through whatever your equivalent of
ofcom regulators are that they'd staged
this and that in the script for it had
been swear words that they would be the
oscars would be looked at being slapped
with like a 10 million dollar fine that
if you were to purposefully you can
accidentally say swear words and it's
about a quarter of a million i was with
a guy from hollywood yesterday on uh the
drinking bros podcast if you script a
swear word in and it's not supposed to
be there it's some
insane fee some ridiculous so i think
that that seems unlikely and just the
reactions from pretty much everyone
including if you play the tape a bit
longer and you see chris
try to get himself kind of back to
what's happening i'm aware he's an actor
and that's their job but
dude that's some he should have got an
oscar for how he dealt with the slap if
that slap was a fake slap
yeah no i mean he was great and he
looked like he was in some you know you
could see the wheels turning in his head
he was like trying to come out well how
do i spin this and keep the show going
and and yeah and somebody was like uh
well he i'm surprised he didn't get
knocked out and my joke you know was
that oh well his he's not chris paper
after all oh very funny very very very
funny
yeah well i go for low hanging fruit
you've seen those slap fighting
championships right
yes those are awesome i love that is
there a concern
is there a concern with that fighting
stuff that we're basically watching
people get cte live on like on air for
our entertainment
i mean that would be the same thing for
the ufc like any you know at least
you're allowed to defend yourself
yes but i mean come on statistically
you're gonna get hit you know probably
fewer times uh in a slap competition
than you are in the ufc yeah that's fair
so that's fair so yeah what about what
about your reflections on why whether
will should have reacted shouldn't have
reacted
um there's a whole spectrum of things
that we could talk about with that with
regards to um
a man's role in you know defending the
honor of his wife and uh oh man that you
throw out the uh throw out the buzz
phrase uh toxic masculinity whether that
plays a role in it um
i mean obviously jada's jada pinkett
smith can defend herself uh she she
doesn't have she doesn't lack for a uh
you know the witch or the charmer and
the ability to be sassy back in a
situation like that so i don't know um
i honestly couldn't even say what i
would do in the same situation i know uh
it would be a step between
what he did what will smith did and what
ted cruz didn't do when somebody made
fun of his wife what's the ted cruz
situation oh uh ted cruz um
in the campaign in 2016 donald trump
basically just straight up called ted
cruz's wife ugly he's like oh you're
married to an ugly woman or some some
sort of thing and then ted cruz's
response to that was to help him
campaign
so ah okay it's a running joke here in
texas you know okay um so i got a yougov
poll the day after
this happened one in five brits think it
was acceptable for will smith to hit
chris rock at the oscars
a majority of britons 57 say that smith
hitting rock was not acceptable 22 say
that smith's actions were acceptable men
26 were slightly more likely than women
17 percent to say his actions were
acceptable perhaps unsurprisingly uh
taking offense many people might
sympathize with will smith taking uh
regarding the joke made about his wife
jada pinkett smith alopecia hairloss but
how many britons reacted in the same way
as smith when they felt offended 14
say that they have punched or hit
someone in response to something
offensive that is a very low number and
i think speaks a lot to the british
passive aggressiveness most britons 80
however have refrained from doing so men
twenty percent twice as likely as women
nine percent to have lashed out
physically this was an interesting one
then this comes to what you just said
there honor bound some have suggested
that jada pinkett smith didn't need her
husband to defend her honor in this way
and that this notion is outdated but
when asked today three quarters of
britain's 77 percent said it is
appropriate for a husband to defend his
wife's honor if another person offends
them one in 10 10 said that it is not
appropriate for them to do so and women
79 are more likely than men at 75
percent to say it is appropriate for a
husband to defend his wife sauna i
thought that was quite interesting
yeah no i mean there's there are deeply
rooted evolved reasons for that um
just i mean at the uh the level of a
woman who sees or that her husband is
not going to do anything just let it
happen it's probably not going to be um
he's probably not going to be her
husband for very long just because i
mean you want to know that that even
irrespective of genders you want to know
that that person is as they would say
down for you to you know the right or
die kind of stuff so you don't
you want to know the person you're with
it would be good in a situation like
that it's got your back and uh but more
so for men because traditionally we are
seen as the gender
that does the more physical
sort of interactions with world
responding to threats and and that sort
of thing
so would it have been different do you
think if jada had gone up and slapped
him
uh absolutely it would have been a 100
different conversation and i think the
vast majority of people would have
cheered it on and i think people would
have even thought that was more scripted
because uh first of all she would have
gotten away with it completely uh there
would have been no controversy minus a
few people that are you know on the the
far the manosphere you know types is
like how dare she how could she slap
that kind of thing but um
no i i think that would have been the
ideal scenario and and if he was just
sitting back there with the camera on
him just clapping
i mean that would be would have been the
perfect way
minus you know just a conversation to
resolve that issue well i mean if will
had leaned over and said darling darling
i already think that you should go up
and whack him that might have taken away
a little bit of the spontaneity there is
there's definitely an argument to be
made that
um
kind of like in roast battles if you go
to an awards ceremony now you know what
you're in for whether it's kevin hart or
ricky gervais or chris rock that's
presenting it
it's kind of the job of the comedian to
take the wankiness
out of this highfalutin very sort of
bourgeois
event by yeah going around the room and
pointing at all of the hypocrisies of
hollywood and making fun of people and
stuff like that so yeah i mean
out of all of the jokes that you can
make about will smith's wife especially
with will smith in the room that's
quite a low ball one there's
you know
stories about him being cooked by his
own wife there's videos of him having
podcast episodes and stuff and i mean
that
that to me is a another interesting
conversation around
why
we have a particular concern about going
after groups let's say that chris rocket
said something racist up on stage right
against any group
condemned across the world but the
insult about one particular person is
significantly more painful to that
person as opposed to an entire group and
yet
everybody's fine for that joke about an
individual person to go but not fine for
a joke about an entire group to go i
find that an interesting disparity
between the way that we judge hurting
feelings or making value judgments goes
yeah i know i i agree i think that uh
had he
i mean we would have absolutely
everybody well most people most decent
people would have taken exception to him
making fun of the alopecia community you
know i mean that
but but going after her
then again um jada herself isn't exactly
the ayla celebrity that will smith is so
going after will smith there's a there's
also a power and balance there you're
there's the i hate the term punching
down yeah sometimes no matter where you
are you you know you kind of deserve to
get punched in some you know
metaphorical sense uh if not literal but
um
it's not going after jada j to pick a
smith is a totally different scenario
than going after will smith who is you
know a plus list hollywood you know
almost at this point royalty now uh some
whole generations have grown up with a
guy uh and then you know she's yeah her
career is not exactly at the same level
so and she's been going through some
stuff and yeah there's so many different
factors at play here that you know i
i welcome all the different takes on it
so i mean personally i've just i've
focused on the part where he his hand
contacts the other guy's face because
you know that's what we're predisposed
to look at
well you are pretty experienced with
this right your background is in
fighting calling out fighting
understanding what it means to sort of
deploy physical aggression and then also
having online confrontations that
sometimes end up in physical aggression
yeah yeah bulshito um got its start uh
oh god back in 2002 almost two decades
now this may it'll be 20 years um
where it was just a bunch of uh mma
athletes martial artists etc people that
are actively training calling out the
people that are just pretending to be
tough guys uh in the martial arts we've
long since expanded our topic range to
more things but back then it you know
this is what we were into and this is
what seemed to be important because a
lot of people had no idea what a real
fight looked like so they had grown up
in the 80s with the you know karate kung
fu action zones and all the ridiculous
yeah especially steven seagal that i've
got a great story with that i i never
refrain from sharing uh about stephen
seagal um
but anyway the um
so the internet was was new online
communities were new uh this was before
people were using the word meme even uh
there were there was no facebook there
wasn't even a myspace back then so we
all kind of got together and just hashed
out our own little a space where we
could call these people out without
being you know censored or shut down or
anything like that and uh it got
interesting and um
i ended up being the uh like
accidentally tyler durden in a sense
because we have all these people like
yeah well you're full [ __ ] you're full
of [ __ ] and we'd have these things where
people get together and just beat the
crap out of each other and we call them
throw downs what's it like running a
real-life fight club
oh it was awesome i don't think there
were no surprisingly there were no real
serious legal consequences for the
fighting because it was
within a martial arts context i mean
these people are sparring it's all you
know consensual yeah we may not have had
exactly uh like waivers or things signed
or anybody got like a clearance from
their doctor or anything official
because it wasn't sanctioned but you
know guys would show up and you know
throw blows and it was it was cool it
was like you know the golden area of the
internet as far as i'm concerned
but this was the same time that kimbo
slice would have probably been doing
backyard brawls
for money yes yeah kimbo slice uh he
kind of did his own thing and i think it
was like florida was where he was coming
up the guys are just throwing punches
and stuff and we just we're doing the
same thing but
those those guys are sort of unregulated
like not even associated with martial
arts at all they were just dudes that
were
like banging it was they were people
that wanted to throw hands it feels like
you guys were trying to stress test
different martial arts uh and or how
much [ __ ]
certain people were talking about online
we would invite people to come and come
to the events most of them were friendly
but every now and then there was some
dude who's like yeah man you guys i
don't like the what you've been saying
about us uh you know we're we're gonna
show up and and uh you know it was
usually hilarious uh we have we had a
couple of famous incidents that are
still on the internet somewhere uh like
one guy showed up at a um to fight a
dude in in a like a backfield somewhere
he actually left like a comic convention
because he was dressed up in cosplay and
showed up to fight the dude the guy from
[ __ ] was in cosplay and showed up to
fight the guy in in the backyard of
somebody's house and um they beat his
ass dressed as like
lupin or some anime character and so
yeah that dude is awesome um and then
we've had one guy that uh we had a whole
crew of people drive like 16 hours from
uh was austin to dc to maryland area or
something to fight a dude in a parking
lot
um over like some challenges like he was
like talk about his kung fu ability
and um the fight itself didn't happen
but a fight between the two people that
had gone with those two groups ended up
doing and it was it was it was pretty
cool that guy ended up on his back and
uh got punched a few times and yeah so
we used to have fun what were the most
common
martial arts that were the ones that
were being called out and what were the
most common ones that were being used to
stress test the [ __ ]
well usually it was somebody that had
trained in
mixed martial arts or brazilian jiu
jitsu specifically because when you do
those things you know exactly what your
limitations are because the guys that
are uh and girls that are going that are
rolling that are sparring in the
classroom they they're sparring they're
they're seeing what they can get away
with and a very loose open rule set
where i mean short of you know
nasty stuff like poking somebody in the
eye or you know trying to bite or that
kind of thing ufc sort of rules you know
what your limitations are and so the
guys that do the sparring like
aikido uh which basically has no
sparring or
styles like wing chun or just other
forms of kung fu not all of them but
most of them they don't do any sparring
at all so they would um they would be
hurt their images would be hurt by the
fact that they had up until we came
along or you know people are similar to
us had um everybody just assumed that
you know you guys yeah i mean you do
this you know you train for 10 years
you're probably a badass and you know
guys like to be thought of as badasses
so yeah their feelings get hurt when
you're like dude you've never even taken
a punch in your life how do you know
that you know all this floppy crap that
you're doing is going to help have you
ever done a whatever more traditional
martial art like a laugher or a kung fu
or a karate or so well i guess karate is
relatively um
applicable in some
aspects but what about the more fluffy
stuff have you ever tried to do that
i um personally uh like when i was first
getting into martial arts just way back
in the 90s i uh i did a little wushu uh
and some wing chun
so i mean i have familiarity with that
um
and then you know uh the ufc came along
and we were like that'd be cool to see
some of those dudes in that and then you
know
you just didn't
i think there was one guy
there was one guy that did wing chun in
the ufc and he um immediately got put on
his back and punched into uh you know
the mat so
yeah the reason that i say that is i did
laugh for
probably six years when i was in my
teens and it was a real formative
part of growing up i was doing tai chi i
was teaching tai chi as well um
and it's strange
thinking now in a world that's stress
tested by ufc i mean it would have been
stressed it was like
four 2004 thousand like once 2006 or
something like that um
i wonder whether you still see a value
in people doing those more traditional
styles of martial arts
i actually i do i do i'm not like i
guess the term would be a bigot against
those those sorts of things first of all
there's the the cultural relevance and
the i mean they're some of those things
are just beautiful to see uh like even
an iq i bag on aikido all the time
because it's it's a goofy style it was
created by it by a weird you know
cultish you know vegan japanese hippie
guy um but uh i there there's there's
beauty in the motion it is a in a way
almost a form of dance uh that reflects
older things and i can even rationalize
how some of that would have been
applicable to a battlefield
hundreds of years ago
it's just so far removed from that
context it's not practical to you know
doing anything today so yeah i mean i i
think tai chi um
especially for the movement you know
it's just like a sort of walking yoga
you know keep yourself limber as you age
and that kind of thing that's that's
great that's good stuff i really enjoyed
it and it was super formative i think
that you're right when you
the problem comes when you start talking
about applicability
and it's the further away from
ufc i mean what else what else is that
i'm going to guess brazilian jiu-jitsu
you're straight up boxing kickboxing
thai boxing samba and then wrestling are
those probably like the main
styles is there anything missing it
really is
well i mean uh
i mean there has been some of the uh
kyokushin karate i think uh was it leo
machida is that the one that's is that
the one where they try and punch each
other in the sternum it's a full contact
just not to the face you can kick to the
head but you can't punch to the head
what's that one that um michael page did
shoot fighting
cute fighting uh yeah i mean well that's
to my knowledge that's just a um
it's just another rule set so and there
was uh there were i think one of those
pancreas was the one where you you had
to use open hands so that was back in
the day that's what will smith should
have learned
ah yeah yeah i mean i think there were a
couple ko's from open hand kos for some
of those dudes
and what do you imagine if will smith
had
ko'd chris rock with a slap
i'm just gonna use chris i'm gonna use
chris rock and will smith now as the
benchmark for the rest of time
for whether or not something's an
effective strategy in martial arts
yeah that works in fact i really want to
give chris credit for taking that
assuming and i'm leaning towards the
fact that it was real assuming that it
was yeah he he he took that like a champ
i mean he just he rolled with the uh the
slap and like i said you could knock
somebody out with a damn slap especially
if the palm of your hand it wasn't a
light rider
will smith's not a small dude he's
trained for pretty much all of his life
and yeah he's a bigger guy for anyone as
well that hasn't ever been slapped or
hit the sensation of being fully slapped
in the face
is pretty shocking like there's the
flood of everything that just comes
through you go
i've just been [ __ ] slapped
yeah you're completely shocked so yeah i
am i think you're right i think
one of many many interesting lessons to
take from that is
chris rock's ability to
hold his poise
in that is pretty impressive
yeah yeah like i said you could see the
wheels turning he was like how can i you
know follow this up with a with a joke
or something and i think what he said
was uh i was like well that was the best
moment in oscar history so
good for that dude man
what about
what do you think
about the importance of learning how to
fight i have this conversation a lot
with friends who are untrained in
a very applicable style of martial arts
right like an mma or a boxing or a
brazilian jiu jitsu
do you think
that it is i wouldn't say a moral
obligation but you could even say that
um a quasi-necessity for especially
men to perhaps spend some time learning
how to fight
yeah well yeah absolutely because i mean
our especially if you have a like a
slightly higher than normal testosterone
account you're going to think that you
can fight
whether or not you actually can
i mean you run into so many dudes that
are like man i i just see red and i just
start throwing you know it's like they
have in this in their head this idea
that
yeah it's just i can goku my way out of
this [ __ ] i can power up this based on
anger and red bull or whatever and win a
fight
when
the difference between and this is one
of the things i try to explain a lot of
people the difference between somebody
who's trained for like just six months
in a brazilian jiu jitsu or a muay thai
or even boxing or wrestling
versus somebody who's you know watched
those things on tv maybe is it's
astronomical the the amount of ability
that that's there just from learning the
basics
so yeah if you care about the people
around you uh whether you're a man or
woman but i mean especially dudes
because we fall into that role a lot
you should
be physically capable to
handle a situation like that whether
it's you know you're confident enough
that if it comes to that you can you can
handle it and but that also reinforces
your ability to de-escalate because you
know at the end of the day de-escalating
even if you have to take a little bit of
hurt to your pride doesn't really hurt
your pride as much as if you were unsure
that you could kick that dude's ass
so it's it's easier to back down from a
fight you're like okay yeah man you're
okay you're tough guy um in a situation
like that when you know that if if you
had to you would have just tore him up
well
the difference there is kind of like the
difference between being homeless or
going camping one of them is a choice
and the other one is mandated on you
it's what
peterson says peterson says you know uh
a harmless man is not a good man a good
man is a very dangerous man that has
that under voluntary control
and that's the difference you're backing
down because it's your choice to because
you want to de-escalate as opposed to
your backing down because that's the
only option that you have that doesn't
involve you getting the [ __ ] kicked out
of you
yeah absolutely it's the uh
better to be a warrior in a garden than
a gardener in a war
yeah that's that's i mean
yeah um
i i it's interesting
there's a a part of me that that knows a
bunch of
dudes that i think would really really
benefit from
spending
a year or a couple of years doing some
brazilian jiu jitsu or some some
striking because
i think there's a lot of nervous energy
around masculinity uh that
comes out due to a fear of inferiority
if anything was to get physical and i
think that
based on what i see i'm right next to
the sauna place that i go to in austin
you mean akuya yet
uh i've i've seen it yeah yeah it's
opposite yeah opposite tenth planet yes
i'm in austin as well we could have just
shouted out the window
okay yeah yeah i'm just down the road we
got hit by the tornado last week oh [ __ ]
yeah uh so
uh kuya which is that i get a lot of the
tenth planet guys that are coming in and
i'll be hearing them talk and all of
them are so softly spoken these
brazilian kids 17 years old with full
cauliflower ears but they're all coming
in and they're all really quietly
talking about whatever it is that
they've got going on
and uh
yeah there's just a sense of sort of
poise and certainty that those guys have
that i think a lot of
um dudes that i know i've worked the
front door of nightclubs for 15 years as
a club promoter and i've watched a lot
of situations in which people who don't
know how to fight have tried to fight
probably because of a fear that they
don't know how to fight
yeah yeah i mean it's uh i like to
compare it to a chihuahua you know
chihuahua knows he's gonna get his ass
kicked but he's he's he's gonna snap and
bark and growl as much as he possibly
can to convince you that he's not gonna
get his ass kicked so there's there's a
little bit of that at play and yeah it's
the overconfidence thing it's just weird
we're dudes are
we're just host to a whole cocktail of
chemicals that send like all these
signals to us like you need to fight or
you know if you don't fight then you
know you're gonna regret it in the
future or all these sorts of things and
they lead to bad decisions and the the
older you get the easier it is to manage
those because you have experience but um
man being a a teenage dude with a with a
little bit of a you know like t running
through you you're
i mean it's easy to go the wrong
direction with with some choices you
look at the
violent crime risk for men and i think
it's between 26 and 29 and it just falls
off a cliff you know and this is why the
vast majority of gang members are at
that young age i mean also
if you've been in a gang for 10 years
since the age of 16 or something you're
probably maybe dead or in jail or one of
a bunch of other things but um yeah one
of the best things that i think that you
could do for young men especially ones
that might live in an impoverished
neighborhood or guys that have got a
little bit more of anti-social behavior
tendencies when they're young is to try
and get them into a place where they can
funnel that aggression right absolutely
yeah for sure create a positive outcome
for that as opposed to it happening on
the street
yeah no i in fact uh er every time that
that that situation comes up you see a
kid in school but public schools aren't
going to do that they're not going to
say hey you should go that we barely
barely even have contact sports in
public schools anymore so i remember
when i was a kid and this was some
podunk rural texas uh like they would
never do this today this is like late
80s actually um we did boxing in gym
class you know we put on big you know
fluffy gloves and we're like just
swinging at each other and there's no
way you could do that today so some nice
30 ounce huge mets that you've got like
comedy ones that you get at a town fair
sock'em boppers you know the toddler
toys but uh you know it was great i
remember being impressed with my ability
because i was you know less than
confident i was a scrawny kid
i uh yeah i was scrawny nerdy kid and so
there's this kid i didn't like and of
course the coaches paired us up because
you know they're they're dicks and
that's what coaches do but um so i mean
i just floored the guy i just spun him
around i threw a punch and yeah he went
you know like a cartoon top and i was
like
huh i might have a affinity for this
sort of thing so
but yeah it was
we need that we need um
not all violence in the sense of the the
sociological you know ivory tower
academic sense of the term is
necessarily
a thing we should avoid uh if we're
learning to express that in a healthy
uh consensual reasonably safe manner
it's probably so much better than just
you know letting people do what they're
going to do without any supervision
one of the things that i've realized is
that a lot of the time policy makers and
people that are doing public commentary
about big important whatever they
consider to be important
rules
aren't built the same as the people that
they're making the rules for so yes one
of the good examples of this is the
feminist movement when they decided that
getting rid of chivalry would be a good
way to further equalize the the world
for women that a man holding a door open
for a woman or men being taught very
very aggressively that you shouldn't hit
a woman you shouldn't do blah blah blah
because women are their own
that was a bourgeois
idea that didn't take into account that
women from slightly different
backgrounds where men perhaps didn't
have as many guard rails in on their
behavior were benefiting from chivalry
still being a thing and as soon as you
get rid of that reason for men to decide
to do it simply because it's a norm in
terms of respect a lot of women that
were from different backgrounds to those
that were promoting the the reduction of
the behavior were the ones that were
going to suffer and it kind of feels
like the same with regards to
violence as well that most of the people
who are going to talk about the toxic
masculine effect of someone going into
an mma gym and learning how to punch
somebody in the face whether that be a
politician or somebody that writes in
the media it's very unlikely if you've
got to that sort of a position in
society that you are the sort of person
who would need a violent outlook or an
outlet for you when you were a 13 year
old raging with adolescent hormones
yeah i mean the similar sort of like
detached from a ground ground reality
thing it comes in like in discussions of
firearms as well it's like why would
anybody need a firearm at their house to
protect you know well the cops are
always there in my neighborhood you know
they'll show up within two minutes if i
call yeah that's not how it is for
everyone else everyone doesn't live in
your your very in your your walled
community with like
security and this and that so yeah
policy needs to be made for the people
that suffer the most it needs to be
focused on those who are more likely to
be victims and not necessarily the the
people that are just
looking at
life through their very stunted small
lenses
so we have very differing opinions about
whether or not to engage in arguments
online
can you can you please put forward your
uh proposition about why you do it
my
okay uh the people i i've actually
written this down in a piece but um
the the idea is that a lot of people
will say don't argue with idiots
because i mean the idiot there's like so
many mark twain had a quote it was like
uh he'll like pull you down with his his
experience or don't um it's like playing
chicken or chest with a with a pigeon
it'll just knock over all the pieces and
[ __ ] on the board so um
i
look at it from a a longer term sort of
spectrum so
you should argue with idiots if
the
if there's an audience so if it's just
you and an idiot i mean you're
unless you genuinely care about that
person and you you want to steer them in
the right right direction you might make
them a non-idiot yeah dude there that
would probably be a waste your time but
when it when you argue with an idiot in
front of an audience just like you're
having a debate with somebody you're
you're talking for the audience so
just don't focus so much on the person
that you're arguing with as in make the
points that other people who are maybe
on the edge uh or the you know they
could go the wrong way
they could go from you know believing in
you know modern medicine to uh
homeopathy or something like that so
steer that argument for those those are
your audience the the idiot
in the argument it's just your punching
bag are you saying are you saying that
online arguing is a spectator sport
it absolutely is in fact the the
algorithms for those things are so
tailored now to to get that to the
engagement because you know uh a twitter
thread of like three people
all agreeing on you know whatever is is
nothing it doesn't nobody's gonna tune
in to look at that but like just people
piling on and just like just this is
that subtweets and threads and you know
yeah cancel mobs and all that [ __ ] yeah
that that's what gets people engaged so
of course
so i mean yeah you have to play in that
battle because there are some people out
there that are pretty good at that
and they're doing it for you know either
selfish or the absolute wrong reasons
so
it's one of those uh on honestly on some
level not to make it sound too grandiose
but you know all that's needed for uh
was it the edmond burke quote i think
was it for uh for evil triumph is good
men to do nothing that kind of thing are
you are you saying that your your online
arguments are a public service
uh actually i literally are spectating
i mean personally i don't know my
arguments are kind of you know for my
own benefit but
as the organization that we run yeah
we're a non-profit educational media
foundation so
yeah they're we're trying to do some
good and you know but maybe if we have a
little fun in it it's it's an incidental
so i think
i think it's only because of the
presence of people like you and and the
people that you argue with that i'm able
to take my stance which is this is
somebody's fight but it's never my fight
like for me an online argument the the
cost to benefit ratio
is just way
way way off and i do think that
there are some people i mean chris
kavanagh is a perfect example of this i
every so often someone will tag me in a
halfway through as an example or you
know when this is one of the worst most
annoying things right about twitter
someone's having a big argument early on
in the exchange you somehow become
tagged as an example or a whatever and
then for the remainder of the day
you have now been dr like by by the
scruff of your neck by the the seat of
your pants your now mentions are just
annihilated by everyone you're just like
desperately hoping that someone decides
to quote tweet it which is kind of like
the ejector seat button that means that
you're no longer a part of this thread
and it's happened with me where i've
been kind of intrigued tagged in at one
point
into a chris kavanagh thing and it makes
me feel physically uncomfortable because
i know that this is going to be a battle
of attrition this isn't going to be
something that's going to be let go this
is going to go on for
many many tens of replies and uh yeah i
i salute you for your uh patience or
perseverance or boredom that that sort
of pushes you to be able to do this
online but dude it's it's not for me
yeah no i mean you have to waste so much
time in it and if you're not seeing
if you're not trying specifically to
affect some kind of change if you're
just trying to engage with ideas
then i i have no i don't begrudge anyone
for saying like yeah this is ridiculous
i'm yes i'm gonna go my phone down um
yeah i'm gonna walk outside touch grass
so
i think that's what they're saying now
what's the steven seagal stories i want
to know more about and you must have
some others about crazy fake martial
artists give us some of those the the
steven seagal story is um and i think
actually i don't give a [ __ ] whether
he's uh you know offended because you
know he gave up his citizenship and now
he's a russian i think so whatever um so
back in the day uh i think forget one of
the movies one of his three word movie
titles um he uh hard to kill like
just kick the ass whatever he um he has
a he had some something on the set and
he was like talking [ __ ] like man uh
like all this stuff and nobody could
like choke me out and that was that was
the claim that he made and um one of the
stuntmen happened to be judo jean
labelle gene labelle is legendary as a
stuntman um and and as a martial artist
i mean judo just extraordinaire guy and
he does not get enough respect and love
over the years i think he's dead uh but
you know anyway so he was he was in so
many movies now that if if you look
through all the old 80s and 90s and
before movies bruce lee stuff um you can
see him in the background you play spot
jean labelle but um
jean labelle was on the set he's like
i'll take you up on that bet and um
so as the story goes um i'm not sure
whether or not steven seagal was wearing
brown pants when he showed up to the set
that day but he certainly left wearing
brown pants and then lawyers got
involved and gene was like you know so
sued for like you know signing
non-disclosure and all that [ __ ] so but
yeah the
gene labelle like put him in a rear
naked joke and made a steven's skull
[ __ ] his pants
wow
yeah and i've had this confirmed by
several people in the industry um and
then over the years it it's so i have
high confidence a lot of faith it's an
urban legend
pooped himself
oh yeah plus i mean i also want to
believe it so yeah well that's that
whatever confirmation bias against
stephen cigar i think everybody has that
what else then because there's been
there was like this period i suppose
i don't know what the wonder years would
have been when
video cassettes you were able to sell of
these magic dojos and you've got these
old and stylish videos of non-touch
knockouts and force pushing and chi
energy and [ __ ] like that
what
wasn't wasn't that movie that uh
what's his face starred in about the
fighting pit wasn't that based on a fake
story as well oh uh yeah van damme
played uh frank dukes and he was
bloodsport yeah and he was that was a
fake story right yeah frank dukes is a
real person um but his whole story is
manufactured like he was a a ca ninja
you know guy that fought an underground
tournament in like in asia called the
kumite um
of back in the day actually this was
even before we got involved in this uh i
think was it
soldier fortune magazine some some um
some publication that wasn't exactly
mainstream like doug like did all the
actual leg work on this track down his
tournament trophy to a um to a trophy
store right down the street from his
house
so
it just i mean they
they source it the whole story is
[ __ ] but frank dukes is still out
there like giving ninja seminars um
and a lot of in europe because you know
very few people in the u.s believe in
ninjas now unless they're into anime but
um yeah so he's still trying to cash in
on that cow and then there was a sheet
of kim
who uh was one of the first big guys we
tangled with she again published a bunch
of books in the 80s like ninja secrets
of invisibility or ninja magic skills or
this or that and so we're like okay and
he had this uh ten thousand dollar
challenge he's like i can defeat anybody
just put ten thousand dollars up so one
of the members of our forums it's like
cashed out ten thousand dollars and put
it in bill stacks of bills on his desk
and like
let's do this and then you know the
hemming and the hong and the
just started and so yeah we we punked
him out
and um
oh god i don't want to tell the story
because this is this is the nerdiest
thing that anyone's ever heard and every
time i've tell this i feel a little a
little ashamed but
so instead of fighting somebody from
bullshitto
he went on wikipedia
and started threatening
the
founder of wikipedia jim wales
and like started saying we should take
down the bullshito article and take down
the article about me because it included
the information about us um you know
calling him out and his 10 000
challenges bs and so jim wales himself
the guy
the head of the wikimedia foundation
deleted ashitakim's article off
wikipedia and so i'm like
how is this a real world thing where i'm
and shitty kim accused him of being in a
rival ninja gang
uh it was just the most bad [ __ ]
this is this could only happen in the
earlier days of the internet where you
know you could actually interact with
people and i was it was so wild and
it's hard to tell the story and expect
people to believe me but it's just it
was a smaller world back then i love the
fact that this guy everything to him
is framed through ninja gangs or not
yeah like everything that occurs the
reason that will smith slapped chris
rock is because they were in rival ninja
gangs yeah so yeah absolutely yeah
we were a different clan or something
whatever uh we we eventually tracked him
down to uh the guy's real name was
radford davis he lived in a trailer in
florida um you know i think we had
somebody uh dig through his garage or
his uh garbage to uh like confirm that
it was uh it was really the same guy and
stuff like that so and we've we've done
a few things uh we're
i don't know if you should be proud of
that but i mean the guy just
there's so many people i remember seeing
those books on bookshelves as a kid at
like a bookstore it's like ninja magic
and a invisibility and i can see how you
get taken in by that it sounds cool as
hell
what were you looking at to do with
chiropractors because i've heard rumors
about the efficacy
of
uh
chiropody
what a chiropractic work yeah
i've heard sort of rumors about this for
ages what's the what's the actual
breakdown of of where it came from and
whether it's effective or not
so uh chiropractic uh was
created in the late 1800s by a man named
d.d palmer
dede palmer up until then had been like
sort of a for the time a grifter snake
oil salesman i think you know
professionally he like like did grocery
distributions or something until one day
uh as the story goes he cracked
somebody's back because you know i mean
cracking your back makes you feel better
and then all of a sudden and keep in
mind that this is in the time period
where there was a lot of interest in
spiritualism and um alter science was
just getting rolling and real scientific
method kind of stuff and we're still
figuring out i think they had just
started washing their hands before
operating on people at the time and so
dede palmer's story that he went public
with to to say the new field of
chiropractic whatever however they say
it is um
was imparted to him in a dream by a
ghost doctor
by a dead ghost doctor so
somehow that became a thing i mean yeah
relentless marketer i mean like steve
jobs level marketing um and so yeah the
the thing that muddies the water on
chiropractic is that a lot of the people
that do chiropractic
just want to help
just basically want to be
physiotherapists just just want to do
physical therapy occupational therapy
that stuff and get you back to you get
your skeletal your muscles and
everything like that all
back working properly because you know
think about do most people sit on their
ass all day or have bad posture or
habits like that and it's a necessary
service your general practitioner is not
going to give a [ __ ] about that they're
going to you know even especially in the
u.s they're going to give you you know
five minutes of attention prescribe you
something and you know
cash in money but
so chiropractors have filled in a gap
where a lot of people like
i i need this kind of i need something
to help me out because i got a shitty
mattress and you know i i'm on my feet
all day and you know so my back hurts
yeah it's gonna hurt
and the part of chiropractic that works
is the actual evidence-based medicine
because they they do some of that they
do chiropractors have when you go to
chiropractor school you learn the the
real things you learn the stuff that
works but you're also the difference is
that you're taught things like
subluxations um which are are not a
thing what's up that uh basically the
bones are misaligned so you're bringing
them back into line usually uh like a
chiropractic subluxation is different
than an actual medical one where things
are really the hell out of whack
chiropractic is like oh well there's
just a you gotta just slightly justify
no
chiropractic teaches uh that you
in its true form chiropractic teaches
that you can cure any disease by
adjusting the spine and that's well
patently ridiculous there's also another
central uh concept of chiropractic
called the innate which is a like a life
force almost like a chi sort of thing
that um you won't hear a lot of the
more
contemporary the the ones that are out
there talking about chiropractors they
won't sell it to you just like
scientologists won't talk about xenu but
it's there and so that's another
fundamental part of their their practice
and so
you can get
all the things that work out of
chiropractic you can get from a
physiotherapist
but the problem is
chiropractors are easier to see they're
more available there
and they do provide
what feels like relief when you get your
back cracked it feels good
the problem is then they'll they'll take
that and expand it and then you'll see
videos of chiropractors cranking the
necks of infants
or uh my my favorite one is i don't know
i guess this guy's a celebrity uh
chiropractor on youtube or something i
don't know the dude's name but there's a
video of him taking like a hammer and
like a chisel device and just he has it
right up against the dude's tailbone and
he's just hammering it just whacking the
[ __ ] out of it with a big little smile
on his face i'm like
no
please i mean unless you're doing that
versus as a stunt or like an episode of
jackass
no that's not a medical thing
so
you can get all the benefits of a
chiropractor by seeing a physical
therapist problem is that they're harder
to access and that's the problem with a
lot of the alternative medicine out
there
it's hard to get good
medicine medicine it's hard to get seen
by somebody that's an expert
why do people choose to become
chiropractors if they want to be
physical therapists is it easier to get
the qualification to be a chiropractor
well it's absolutely easier to be to
become a chiropractor the the uh the
licensing and
regulation that i mean
simply because it's less of an
evidence-based practice so
i mean [ __ ] is an inherent part of
it can chiropractors call themselves
doctor
uh you can be a doctor of chiropractic
so
technically yes right okay yeah i was
pretty sure that i'd seen
something around that that whatever like
dr fletcher is and it's a status thing
right you say the word doctor or you
don't know if you're a doctor of law or
a doctor of
chiropody or whatever philosophy yeah
precisely what are you gonna do you're
gonna like debate my back better yeah i
know it's like that that meme it was
like a is there a doctor on board the
airplane uh yeah yeah i'm a doctor of
philosophy i was like well he's gonna
die he's like we're all gonna die
but uh yeah so they but they they take
advantage of the fact that there is a
doctor in the
the uh the fuzzy gray area in the public
understanding of the word doctor versus
physician
uh which is the term that you know it's
it's more you know appropriate to call
the medical doctors now because
everybody can be you can be a doctor of
education or basket weaving or whatever
now and um
have you ever looked at um the evidence
behind acupuncture or dry needling or
anything like that
um i haven't delved into it in depth i
so i i'm loath to speak on that
um because i'm not i try not to chime in
on stuff that i don't have a firm solid
grip on it i mean my intuition says it's
it's hokia stuff because i know a lot of
the things considered for example uh
just to specify one thing traditional
chinese medicine
that term traditional chinese medicine
is a entire um fabrication
from the mao era of china because they
were
there was a sort of deficit of actual
physicians so they they wanted to like
institute some sort of nationalistic
health care
and so they ramped up the idea of
traditional chinese medicine i mean
every every culture has its own
traditional medicine herbs and you know
that that sort of thing and
folk remedies and so but they played
that up to us like a state thing they
they milled it in with the um
like
the chinese national identity for a
while and so it's still deeply
entrenched in there so you'll you'll
find journals um chinese which you know
i'm not good enough on duolingo to read
it yet um but uh it's
you'll find some that are just like
inspect you'll find chiropractor
journals that sort of launder the the
ideas that they're trying to put into
the mainstream for medicine because as
the saying goes um
alternative medicine that actually works
it's just called
just medicine
i
have been thinking about this for quite
a while like what it is
about these different
pathways where people seem to show some
sort of recovery afterward and i had
this guy on david robson who's just
written a book called the expectation
effect a man
this [ __ ] blew my mind absolutely blew
my mind so you understand the placebo
effect right that one of the most
replicable effects in pharmacology is
this panacea where the placebo effect
accounts for sometimes over 50 of the
impact of particular drugs and
the expectation effect which is david's
new book goes through this is present in
anything that you care to care about man
like absolutely everything my favorite
there's um something called a
no sibo as well which is a negative kind
of like a hypochondriac that that
creates their own
um symptoms
gluten intolerances
were three percent
10 years ago and they are 30
of people now but think about the last
10 years we've had a lot of messaging
around the dangers of gluten and
bloating and hives and sensitivity and
all that stuff and gluten-free foods as
well which further reinforces that
uh so
researchers brought people who
um
did and didn't have biological gluten
intolerances
into the lab
they fed all of these people food which
did not contain gluten but told all of
these people that it did
and you ended up with people who
weren't allergic to gluten
who hadn't eaten gluten
having a gluten reaction yep and this is
the power of expectation and i this is
where
more degrees of freedom i think need to
be given
when we're talking about alternative
solutions to things
because
you can't deny the fact that that person
does have diarrhea does have hives does
have bloating
the problem is it's not because of the
reason that they think it is and let's
roll that into something else let's say
that it is um
acupuncture right that somebody having
faith let's get beyond the fact that
simply spending a bit of time doing some
self-care in a quiet room with some nice
incense burning is a way to activate
your parasympathetic nervous system for
a while which might be the only part of
your entire week where you're not
thinking about the kids and debt and
whatever which is
a value and it's like that's a genuine
value outside of the expectation effect
then on top of that the fact that you've
done something that feels like self-care
that makes you feel like you're in
control so
it's such a bizarre situation to be in
right because the let's say i don't know
the
studies in acupuncture let's say that
acupuncture doesn't have an impact on
this person's injury or whatever it is
they're trying to do
but they feel better because of the very
very robust and effective expectation
effect you go okay
did the acupuncture work
well
it didn't work for the reason that you
thought it worked it didn't work on the
mechanism that you thought it was
working on
but you can't deny the fact that by
going and doing this thing the person
feels better so the outcome that you
needed is created just not through the
means that you thought it was and it's
just it's such a really interesting
like world to think about the fact that
what you're actually looking to do with
a lot of people especially if they're
trying to fix ailments is actually find
the solution i mean what would be ideal
would be to find the solution that
speaks to them which also assists them
genuinely through some sort of
biological mechanism but failing that
finding a mechanism which uh finding a
solution which speaks to them
to maximize that expectation effect
is
perhaps slightly disingenuous but
actually something that if you're
thinking what's the best way we can get
good outcomes for this person that could
actually be a really really effective
way to look at it
yeah no i don't begrudge anyone for
seeking a remedy
to alleviate their suffering to reduce
their suffering in any way it's just
the the issue that i have i mean it's on
two levels the systemic issue is that we
have
a broken health care system with all the
wrong incentives and all the wrong
priorities and it's just not
serving the public health
so but um from the second level
on an individual level
if you find something that treats um a
problem makes you
feel better okay that's the symptoms but
you've got to treat the actual problem
too like the the biggest example that i
always go back to is that steve jobs
would be with us today
if he hadn't
sought out alternative
um means of treating his actual
pancreatic cancer
80 chance of survival right absolutely
it was one of the few most pancreatic
cancers will just ruin you we'll just
kill you but he had the one that was
treatable by modern medicine and he
instead he sought out all kinds of hokey
nonsense so yeah i mean bs killed steve
jobs the alternative medicine did
because
he had in his head that we can take care
of this problem
uh by you know it's like okay well you
know no
do what you need to do do the right
thing and that's that's where
that's where i get frustrated at all of
the uh
all the problems with uh alternative
medicine it gets in the way if you want
to be on the side you know i don't have
a problem with somebody you know burning
essential oils or whatever in their
house as long as you're getting your
chemotherapy as well yeah yeah i mean
don't don't skip the chemo so that you
can smell lavender you know
yeah i am
i do i do understand i also think that
there's probably a threshold here
if you've hurt your internal rotation of
your shoulder
and
that's that's the degree to which you're
playing [ __ ] with typical versus
non-typical solutions for it
okay the externalities there aren't too
bad if you're playing with i've got
pancreatic cancer
it feels like it's a little bit more of
a serious discussion and you should i
don't know maybe maybe go with modern
medicine but it it seems generally at
the moment that there is a
i i'm going to be interested to find out
what happens post pandemic
generally around um people's views
of
typical medicine big pharma overall you
know we already had the seeds sowed um
with people being disgruntled to do with
uh
opioid addiction for pain medicines we
recently had that uh what was that
series about the family that created
oxycodone that was oh yeah the sacklers
yes there was there's been like i think
a documentary a real documentary and a
dramatized series that's kind of like a
quasi-documentary
about them and it just seems like
we there there is probably going to be
and the problem with this is right that
when it comes to do i really need this
tablet to fix my back pain can you not
just refer me to
a pt
um
that is a virtuous skepticism
around
big pharma and yet you're there's how
much babies going out with the bath
water here does this lead to people
maybe not getting uh cancer treatments
that they really really need and steve's
jobs in it
it's a difficult one man this is one of
the things and we're seeing this
everywhere
the
the danger and the challenge of just
lots of information
we presumed that people who were better
informed who had access to an unlimited
amount of information would be able to
get better outcomes
kind of not the case right because for
every good thing that's out there
there's maybe five or six contrary
conflicting mutually conflicting bad
things so more information isn't always
the solution
i i exactly and if you don't know how to
process information you're going to be a
victim of bad information and that's
kind of one of the things that we try to
focus on since we don't necessarily do
martial arts as much anymore because i
mean honestly it's not an existential
threat there's bigger things going on in
the world we're focused on self-defense
against [ __ ] that's what bulshito is
doing now because we're trying to teach
people how to think to be responsible
consumers of information because if you
don't have the tools to defend yourself
against all that [ __ ] you're going
to be somebody else's tool yourself
you're going to be they're going to
manipulate you into voting against your
own interests to buying products you
don't need to living a lifestyle that is
inauthentic and so
there's just so many our whole system
from the ground up is
almost predatory in a way and so i
understand how people are like
skepticals like i don't believe anyone
with this amount of power i don't you
know
pharmaceutical industry is out there and
they're trying to make profits and they
don't do not they legitimately do not
give a crap about the the end user
that's not they're not ethical entities
and you can't like you're not going to
try a pharmaceutical company for for
murder you can't put them in jail you
you can't you know can't even uh capital
punishment you can't execute a company
uh not at least not in the system that
we have so
i get it i understand the skepticism so
i what i want to do is i mean what
everyone sort of has a moral obligation
to do is
go train
train their their their understanding
how to read news how to parse news how
to how to see okay this is agenda-driven
[ __ ] this is what is this agenda
because everybody has an agenda
but
where is the actual underlying fact in
all of that
sort through that and try and find the
the actual path to navigate through that
because it's
a and the saddest part about it
as i think about it is that most people
don't have the free time they don't
they're busy living their lives they're
busy trying to enjoy those lives
and and so
even the few people that are out there
just like you know uh wired in a weird
way to be you know like like i am to to
try and say no no this is bs this is bs
i mean what's my agenda i mean are you
going to believe me because i'm not you
i have my own thoughts and priorities
and stuff like that so
it's it's hard and so i mean we have to
be better at communicators and as a
community
uh like to
push the bad actors out at least
marginalize them and to try and have
conversations so that we reach the
people that that have questions
legitimate questions and concerns and
fears and because those are the people
first people that get prayed on by the
uh by the grifters the con artists the
uh
the the mustache twirling [ __ ] and
the you know
and the big pharma companies and that
kind of thing yeah the top hats and
their canes that they're twiddling along
yeah i understand it's um
it's never been so difficult
to be
a person
just trying to work out what the [ __ ]
going on
you know now yeah i don't know maybe in
the past the information that you would
have got by your local baron or whatever
would have probably not been very
truthful but at least it wasn't on you
if it was
you didn't need a sophisticated
sense-making apparatus to try and
actually discern what was happening and
i can't work out
it's a genuine question whether or not
it's better to live in a world with
sub-optimally accurate information which
you don't need to spend most of your
time trying to discern or a world in
which you have access to all of the
information but every single mistake
that you make is on your head because
you didn't do enough fact checking
before you decided to make a decision do
you know what i mean yeah yeah no i
don't think we're gonna be able to
escape that unless we just sort of have
some kind of
apocalypse and we regress back to the
[ __ ] time for mad max i'm in for mad
max
[ __ ] it let's do it look ladies and
gentlemen frost it's been a pleasure
where should people go if they want to
check out your stuff
um uh i'm on twitter at p-h-r-o-s-t uh
but bullshitto.net is the website we
have podcast uh we live stream on twitch
and that kind of thing and so uh we have
forums on bullshito.net uh forums are
still okay they're they're not the the
as cool as like you know twitter and
stuff like that for the cool kids but i
think we can have better conversations
on that and i wish everybody would
engage more on that kind of medium but
uh other than that yeah hey just uh
do your own you know research you know
so i appreciate you
cheers man all right thanks man it's
been great what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace